let's go to our next caller from the 843
area code caller from 843 by all means
take it away hello can you hear me yeah
that's you go ahead we're not on speaker
are we oh okay sorry I have my son
speaker you did what got her now thank
you bingo that's gonna be one of the
barn things go ahead yeah but I'm Marcy
and from South Carolina and I wanted to
ask you about with China
I think they recently voted for the
president so you can have unlimited
terms and I think the truth of that I'm
saying I'm approved I mean you think
that Trump do you think that he'll ever
like openly entertain the idea like I
feel like he'll just go on Twitter one
day and like talk about it like probably
not do anything about it but just be
like you know like unlimited terms like
you know like this would be a good thing
or whatever he already did actually he
already said that it's a nice idea and
maybe it's something we might try
someday so he's already said that it's
it's something he'd be interested in but
no I don't actually think Trump is going
to he'll listen people said Obama was
going to declare martial law as a
pretext to suspend the 2016 election in
order to justify and definitely becoming
president and then the military would
come like would become his personal
police force and people would be put in
internment yeah I don't even remember
the full scope of it and of course there
was not even like a 2% chance that it
was ever even going to be considered by
Obama and I also don't think Trump's
going to do it I think that he loves the
idea of president for life and he hates
the fact that he could criticized and
why not why he would love it but no I
don't actually think Trump's gonna try
to cancel future elections and become
president for life although he would
love it yeah I mean of course like I
mean he just says whatever he doesn't
really get anything even when Trump says
he likes the idea of president for life
does he really like has he actually
thought of it or was it five minutes
before he went onstage someone's like
hey the Chinese president has can see it
has extended term limits
so that now he could be president for
life and Trump's like that's kind of
cool maybe we'll try it sometime like
with no regard whatsoever for the
foundation of this country and how it's
totally antithetical to everything that
George Washington had in mind I don't I
don't genuinely know how much thought
Trump even puts into it you know it's
like yeah it sounds kind of cool maybe
we'll do it someday yeah I mean he just
says stuff wish oh well you know I think
it's out of stupidity I don't know that
it's actually shock value but I think a
lot of it's out of out of stupidity all
right thanks for the call really
appreciate it and that's gonna do it for
calls today sorry for everybody we did
not get to we never get to everybody but
we do the best we can and we'll take
calls again very very soon